you can use endpoint checks to monitor
the uptime of any of your web facing
resources to create your first endpoint
check click on the create and endpoint
check button on your monitoring console
if the endpoint that you want to check
is an app engine module select App
Engine in the resource type drop-down
then choose your module then simply test
the endpoint here you see that I have a
successful response and save the end
point if the endpoint is a GCE vm
instance or a group of instances you'll
select instance from the resource type
drop-down and then choose whether you
want it to apply to the group or a
single instance again select your
instance test the end point and click
Save finally you can use generic
endpoint checks to monitor the uptime of
any internet accessible hostname or URL
in this case you'll want to choose
generic end point as the resource type
then you enter your host name such as
cloud google com you can specify an
endpoint path here I'll say that I want
to check the monitoring page on cloud
google com you can specify an interval
for the checks here I'll choose one
minute I'll test my endpoint and I'll
save it at that point you're prompted to
create an alerting policy so that you
can be notified when the check fails and
on the next screen you'll configure your
notification options in this case I just
want to be emailed when the endpoint
check fails so I'll enter my email
address and then I'll save the policy
you should note that it can take a few
minutes for the endpoint checks to
propagate through our system to view the
status of any of your endpoint checks
click on the alerting link on the top of
the screen and end points from there
you'll see a list of all of your
configured endpoint
as well as their status from each of our
probing locations you'll also see an
indication of whether there are any
alerting policies active associated with
the endpoint checks from this page you
can also edit any of your endpoint
checks directly so that's how you can
get started using cloud monitoring's
endpoint check feature we hope that it
helps you identify issues that are
impacting your end users more quickly